[Music]
there's lots of amazing food in the
philippines but there's one amazing
culinary tradition that's big enough to
feed an army
hi i'm jacques and i own buddha fight
manila poodle bootle what what's a
buddha fight
[Applause]
a buddha fight is a feast set up on
banana leaves just a food pile in the
middle with everyone standing shoulder
to shoulder
and the best part is everyone eats with
their bare hands
it originated with the philippine
military soldiers took the practice home
and it went mainstream
so mainstreamed that chefs like jaff now
have full-time jobs bringing buddle
fights to the masses the boodle fight is
a quintessential example of how
filipinos value sharing especially when
it comes to food
a lot of food is needed for woodland
pride to be enjoyed the way it's meant
to be we love balintawak market this is
where buddha fight comes together
we'll be needing the essentials pork
chicken
seafood
veggies dessert the sides and of course
the fruits and do not forget the start
of the show the banana leaves
i am full already
we start with the messy part the
grilling first the pork
chicken
the seafood and then you slice the
fruits
steam the veggies together with the
shrimp and the crab and then slice all
the sides and prepare the table
after setting up the banana leaves it is
important to look for the center of the
table and start from there you can place
the dessert and fruits
then on both sides start with the rice
pork chicken and seafood to make it
extra delicious add the sides literally
on the side of the table the philippines
has a lot of choices when it comes to
food but none compared to the community
that develops when sharing a pile of
food bare-handed with the people you
love
[Music]
you